I am kind of excited that you're going
to do something with the safety Brothers
yes yes I'm going to be in there too yep
me and Jen are going to shoot that are
you really going to be in it well we
just found out
because that would be amazing it would
be amazing I know say it right there
right okay that's why I sincerely hope
that happens uh what can you tease about
the project and I'm also curious I'm
also a fan of the morning show and I
read that you're going to do a body swap
comedy with Julia Roberts that's cool is
that actually happening and what can you
tease about Morning Show yeah the
nothing's funny about mercy so I'm
kidding uh it's uh what Morning Show is
there's a lot of romance
this year and there's a lot of
um Secrets oh
that's good to know that will be
revealed that's good yeah and body Swap
and body swap is in the it's in the
making it's in the cooker you and Julius
will have Soul Children
forever and ever I'm all in on dream of
mine that's a big one for for the the
for the the masses
yes safeties ate dinner with them last
night after we finished nice we talked
about the script it's cool it's cool I
can't I can't give you it's what she
gets in the sports memorabilia world and
and uh I know I can't I don't know what
I I just kind of want them to decide how
they want to present it wouldn't you
serve them we're working on that for I
think this summer this summer I think so